so there's the story about the novelists
kurt vonnegut and joseph heller
attending a party together by the way
good morning heck it's tuesday the
party's an extremely lavish affair
hosted by a billionaire and vonnegut
says to heller joe isn't it funny that
our host makes more money in a day than
you ever made from your beloved
best-selling novel catch-22 and heller
is like yeah that is funny but i have
something our host will never have and
vonnegut says what's that and heller
says
enough i've used this story for years to
remind myself that i have enough but
also to remind me that most people on
earth do not have enough many people do
not have enough food or enough clean
water and most people do not have enough
savings or enough to access excellent
medical care but in my experience even
those of us who do have enough often
feel as if we don't there's always
something missing more security or power
or money that stands between us and true
enoughness for me it's always been about
security the feeling i am trying to
avoid all the time is precarity the
feeling of being close to the edge and
not having a say in whether i go over it
but of course having adequate distance
from precarity turns out to be one
impossible and two insofar as it is
possible actually a pretty terrible idea
let's start with why it's impossible
wealth and privilege insulate people
from many kinds of precarity in
profoundly unjust ways and i think that
is important to acknowledge but
ultimately there is no getting around
the big precarity which is that i and
everyone i love will die when i was
young i thought i could solve this
problem by writing books that would last
books that would survive even though i
wouldn't but i eventually realized that
is of course a fool's error and books
also don't live forever and anyway like
that's not why books exist they exist to
be helpful to the people who find them
and then my next idea was that even if
my work couldn't last my legacy could
through philanthropy like i would build
up this huge charitable trust and then
once it was really big it would start
donating five percent of its resources
per year or whatever to great charities
and then my impact would stretch through
the years the problem with this strategy
is that i was still trying to maintain
some kind of control or agency that
would survive even after my body didn't
right also i was conveniently forgetting
the fact that if you donate money now
it's true that it no longer grows under
your control but it still grows it grows
in the form of more kids surviving to
adulthood and more people having
educational opportunities and so on and
that growth is actually much more
transformational and important than like
the appreciation of stocks now i want to
be clear that i insulate myself from
precarity in as many ways as possible
like i quit smoking 20 years ago because
it was making my life more precarious i
have insurance to make my life less
precarious and i have financial security
which makes a billion things less
stressful and more possible from taking
professional risks to getting my kids
any support they need and of course it's
human wonderfully human to try to
protect those we love there's nothing
wrong with that but one thing i have
noticed over the years is that when rich
people only spend time with other rich
people they do not feel rich they feel
normal and this arrives at what i really
don't like about the people who have
enough it is so easy to forget that we
have enough in fact let me stop using we
and start using i i forget that i have
enough because in trying to insulate
myself from precarity i can also make
myself distant from the reality of
suffering and if i were more proximal to
that suffering i would use more of my
resources to try to alleviate it and too
often in trying to insulate myself and
those i love from the realities of
suffering i am also looking away from
injustice and inequity and
impoverishment and if having enough
means having enough to not have to face
those realities
then enough is simply too much
hank i'll see you on friday